- Bonsoir, ici Pierre Lapointe.
Bienvenue au Premier
Gala de l'ADISQ.
- Pierre Lapointe, vous avez
animé le Premier Gala de l'ADISQ
mercredi soir dernier. Ça va
être rediffusé à 18 h dimanche,
avant le Gala de l'ADISQ
Vous avez beaucoup insisté
cette année sur la relève. C'est
important pour vous. Pourquoi?
PIERRE LAPOINTE
auteuromompositeur-interprète
- Très tôt dans les réunions
avec l'équipe de l'ADISQ...
j'ai juste dit : "Bien...
si j'étais un nouvel artiste
ququi sort son premier album
en pandémie, ce serait
la fin du monde."
Donc, j'ai juste amené l'idée.
Je msusuis dit : ce serait
bien si on choisissait
quelques artistes établis
qui parrainaient des artistes
qui viennent de sortir
leur premier album, qui
commencent en ce moment.
Et j'ai lancé ça comme ça.
L'ADISQ a récupéré l'idée.
Et ils ont décidé d'en faire
l'espèce de but ultime
de l'ADISQ cette année.
- En 2019, vous y êtes allé
avec un coup de gueule
sur les géants du Web.
- Il faut marteler
au gouvernement qu'on veut
que ces grandes compagnies
paient des impôts et
participent à la création
de nouveaux contenus canadiens!
(cris et applaudissements)
- Vous avez pas la langue dans
votre poche. Et vous êtes en
nomination pour le grand Gala de
dimanche soir. Si vous gagnez,
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire?
Est-ce que vous avez déjà
commencé à y penser?
- Je pense que cette année,
ce n'est pas le temps de
faire des coups de gueul
D'ailleurs, j'ai laissé
le dossier... tous les dossiers
qui pouvaient être un peu...
épineux, en tempanananandémie,
pour moi, c'était pas le temps.
Je pense que les politiques...
avaient d'autres choses à faire.
Quand je pj'j'j'j'ai souvent
l'air d'être spontané,
mais c'est très étudié,
je connais bien mon dossier.
J'écs s s s mes discours.
J'écris pas ce que je dis.
Et il y a eu des discussions
autour avec des gens
i i i i i pour être certain
de le faire au bon moment
avec les bons arguments.
J'essaie de le faire le plusrars
le bon moment pour pas non plus
brûler ma parole à tout vent.
- Comment choisissez-vous
vos combats? Parce qu'en 2018,
vous avez participé à Urgence
homophobie, à la chanson
"De l'amour", justement,
parce qu'on sait qu'à...
- En France, oui.
- Oui, à l'époque
des réseaux sociaux...
- ça peut être difficile.
- ... Ça peut être difficile.
Donc, pourquoi vous avez décidé
de participer à ça et comment
vous faites vos choix?
- Il faut seulement que
ça me concerne puis que je sente
que je peux défendre un sujet.
♪ Sans limites sans retour
de l'amour ♪
Bon, la lutte contre
l'homophobie, c'est sûr
que ça me touche. Il y a
la Fondation Émergence qui m'a
donné un prix qui m'a vraiment
ému... le printemps dernier...
pour finalement seulement avoir
été moi-même... ce qui est
étrange, mais en même temps,
ce qui veut dire beaucoup
quand on fait partie
de la communauté LGBTQ+.
Je reste sensible à tous
ceux qui sortent de la norme
et qui en souffrent. Voilà.
♪ ♪ ♪"Le columbarium"!
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ J'ai tout léché les vitrines,
bravant le columbarium ♪
- Je veux souligner
un anniversaire. Il y a pas loin
s,s,s,s,s,s,s, vous avez remporé
le Festival de la chanson
de Granby. Ça a changé,
évidemment, votre vie. l l l l ,
quand même.
(rires)
- Je sais pas, mais en tout cas,
la mienne, ça
beaucoup de choses, oui.
- Avec le recul,
comment vous voyez ça?
- Ce qui s'est passé à Granby,
exexexexexexextraordinaire.
À l'époque, je ne voulais pas
faire de chanson. J'étais allé
là un peu... parce que ça avait
l'air de vouloir fonctionner,sas
mes chansons, et puis...
J'avais écrit quatre chansons au
moment où j'ai remporté Granby.
J'étais très, très bouleversé.Jn
scène. Je voulais être directeur
artistique. Je voulais être
acteur. Je voulais monter
des... des spectacles, faire
des installations étranges.
J'étais étudiant en arts visuels
à l'époque, à l'UQAM, ici,
à Montréal. Euh...
Et c'est comme si la vie
m'avait dit : "Tu pourras
faire tout ce que tu veux
en passant par la chanson."
Et je trouve que le médium
sosososososososon, c'est un médm
extraordinaire parce qu'on peut
se permettre d'être un pied
dans l'avant-garde et un pied
dans la pop pure et dure.
♪ Dans la forêt des mal-aimés ♪
♪ Chaque arbre
est un membre oublié ♪
- Autre anniversaire : 15 ans
de "La forêt des mal-aimés".
Je me souviens très bien de
la première écoute, ce qui s'est
passé dans m j j j j j j j j j'.
Comment on vit avec un aussi
gros disque dans ses valises?
- Bien, c'est déjà... Je suis
chanceux parce qu'il y a des
gens qui font toute une carrière
sans avoir un album qui marque
les esprits autant que ça.
C'cecececececececece que ça va..
bien, ça fait 15 ans. Moi, je ne
l'écoute plus, cet album-là.
J'ai de la difficulté
à l'écouter parce que c'est
des choses... c'est des choix
que j'ai faits à l'époque,
avec lesquels j'étais en phase
à l'époque. Aujourd'hui, je sui-
être pas fait ça comme ça.
Maintenant, c'est une grande
fierté parce que je sais
qu'il habite encore
le quotidien de plusieurs
personnes et qu'il risque
d'habiter le quotidien
des gens encore longtemps.
Euh... c'est une grande fierté.
Et c'est drôle, parce que j'ai
fait plein de trucs depuis.
Souvent, les gens me parlent
de corororororororororors que
j'en ai sorti... je ne sais
plus, une quinzaine au moins.
Et puis... Mais ça me rend quand
même heureux parce que, comme...
il y a des gens qui vivent même
pas ça une fois dans leur vie.
- En terminant, Pierre Lapointe,
après votre triomphe, il y a
un an et demi, à l'Usine C
avec votre tournée "Déjouer
l'ennui", qui a été arrêtée
à cause de la pandémie,
vous reprenez la route.
J'ai hâte de vous revoir.
Merci pour cette entrevue.
- Merci.
♪ Toi qui sais manier la joie ♪
♪ Où as-tu app